هذه السيده جاءت للتو من هاتاي وهي متعبه
ومريضه واود ليال سريعا ان نستمع الى
مشكلتها وما الذي تعاني منه الحمد لله على
السلامه اولا يلا يسلمك حضرتك كنت وقت وقت
الزلزال بالبيت كنت بالبيت على وجهي ضلي
تي
ضليت بالغرفه نعم لا راحت الهزه لحسين من
هالدرج كمان هالرده
وقفنا تحت المطر طول الليل
بعدهم جينا الصبحيات على بيتنا
رجعنا يعني
اغراضي كله مي
ايه وبركنه البيت البيت انهدم لا الحمد
لله ما انعدم بس يعني تضرر تشقق
طيب انت انت مريضه او ايش مالك
انا بعتوني من سوريا من مستشفى مستشفى
المركزي يعني انت جئت من سوريا سكنتي في
انطاكيا حدث الزلزال للعلاج يعني
هذا نصر العلاج بسوريا وحولوني لها ون
كمل ولما جئتي صار الزلزال
يدخل على المستشفى صار الزلزال لا حول ولا
قوه
حالي سلامتك طب انت ايش المشكله الصحيه
اللي عندك ايش بوجعك
[موسيقى]
توجعني كثير معدتي ولا بقى احسن يقبل اكل
اشرب وان
اكلتا سلامتك
يعني انت الان تحتاجي لنقل الى المستشفى
مستشفى مختص بالسرطان
ضروري ايه المستشفى لسرطان على شاشه
العربيه وان شاء الله ويكون صوتك وصل ونحن
في مركز ايواء مركز حماه هنا في انطاكيا
في في هاتاي تعبان كثير
سلامتك الف سلامه اكلت اليوم اكلتي شيء
هذا استفرغتها